What can be done for eye brands, itching?
Eye brands, so if you have a side effect of a medication and eye brands is
medication that is used for breast cancer. So a side effect of a
cancer medication
you're just going to have to deal with the symptom itself.
So
for instance, a lot of there's a lot of side effects in
use of immunotherapy
medication for all sorts of cancers because it causes
you know, basically a person to start to develop autoimmune disorders of various types and
and how do you deal with that? Well, you can't make those things go away. You're just dealing with the symptoms.
If you so
one thought in the natural world is let's help with detox pathways to help get rid of that medication. So you don't have
the side effects, but the negative of that is then you lose if you actually achieve that outcome.
You will be detoxing the medication, so it wouldn't be working as well on the cancer. So I would caution that thought process.
So
if you're taking a medication
or for a disease
and it's working for the disease and you have side effects from that medication
and you've chosen to take that medication, then you're just going to have to deal with the symptoms of the side effects and when you're dealing with
itching from a medication, you think of it's causing an allergic reaction, then you think of you could take things to help decrease histamine levels.
You could take things topically to decrease histamine levels.
From a medical doctor, they may give you a prescription for steroids.
From an alternative doctor, they may give you things like clear histamine scavenger to help decrease that you could try over the
counter at a histamine, things like that.
I wouldn't like try to really ramp up detoxification processes because while it may work, it would also hinder the reason why you're taking the medication in the first place.